[Music]
6 25 on your friday morning what's
driving you crazy oh no
say it isn't so oh so blanca that is
we're talking about where the 95 meets
the northern 215 beltway
come on let's go
centennial bowling all right you
faithful viewers you'll recall we've
talked about this more than once the
frontage road just west of the 95
getting a huge makeover
part of the centennial bulls final phase
but for others
that message signed by the side of the
road north of the 215 it has been a
shocking
wake-up call oh so blanca
to close february 7th for three years
yeah your eyes are lying osoblanca will
close february 7th at super bowl sunday
for
three years as seen in this video from
the 8 news now drone the street that
runs under
elkhorn next to mountain ridge park down
to the 215
is no longer an exit from the beltway
for now the new and improved oso blanca
itself is going to run
under the 215 but when all is said and
done there will be
non-beltway connections both north and
south of the 215 between oso blanca on
the west
and sky point on the east side of the 95
until then
you've got to get used to some detours
for southbound drivers you want to take
durango to the 215 for access obviously
to the beltway or to the south 95.
for northbound drivers here's what
you're going to have to do take the
northbound 95
get onto the beltway west to durango
because oso blanca is going to be closed
for three years all this information is
on our website eightnewsnow.com you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight eight news now
dot com john